hey guys and welcome back to the realm
of roller coasters in this episode I'm
still declaring war on path covers but
also placing flowers which as you may
know is one of my favorite things to do
in this game I know that sounds pretty
stupid and I don't know if I've talked
about this earlier in one of the let's
play videos because my memory is really
bad but yeah when it comes to placing
flowers there is one thing that I really
noticed about many people what they do
is they take one flower and they spread
it all over a really large section of
their park or like in one area and then
I take another flower and then spread
that flower around that area and then
take another flower etc so you got a
really overall blend of flowers
everywhere in the same sort of way which
is something that I really really advise
against a tiny bit variation between one
area is always something that I like to
get in and this is more realistic
flowers aren't a natural thing they are
planted and of course you want to have
them in the nicest way so getting some
nice patterns in with colors matching
specific colors of flowers with other
colors of flowers is really something
that it's not only fun to do in the game
but also results in much more realistic
flower beds so yeah I always kind of
like to do that a tiny bit also dumb
place too many flowers don't ever do
that I was already very hesitant when I
was trying to place this many flowers in
this area as I was going to be I think
at some point that I did say that I
wanted to fill all the planters with
flowers that is definitely not something
that I was going to do which is why I
actually placed these more hedge like
things as well as those other like cones
and other little more fancy trees but
not exactly flowers in the planters
because I really didn't want to get this
entire thing to become a colorful blend
of just screaming bright colors and
flowers so that's why I kind of wanted
to mix in a tiny bit of quote-unquote
normal foliage as well which is not only
to relieve this area of
being a complete and utter just
flowerbed for every sort of variation
you can find I really just wanted to get
more trees in here to get foliage that
actually has a height and make it look
less like one very large open place I
know I've said that I wanted to make
this area look open but actually to get
a more open inviting look I always like
to get some slightly larger foliage in
as well to break up the very monotone
sort of flatland over here it's not
always necessary to do that when you've
got like terraforming going on this is
something when I've got terraformed
Hills for example with flowers I am less
prone to usually get larger foliage in
as well but when it's a completely flat
land like this with just paths and path
covers I mean paths and planters I want
to get some higher footage in as well to
kind of blend in with the lower things
and make this early look a lot more
inviting and green overall so that's why
I did get that in the end other than
that Morrow I have no idea what I'm
going to do with this waterside I was
pretty much just placing this tree over
here and a couple of other stuff as well
just to kind of close that gap between
the Dutch area and the English area
which is honestly something that I still
really have the transition from the
English area to the touch area is I
think it's pretty fluent there is no
really big change with path covers even
though there is a change it goes pretty
smoothly with the train tracks there is
no Sun clashes of buildings but it is a
very sudden transicare transition and
wouldn't like to get a tiny bit more
foliage in between it's just to make
that transition from the Dutch area to
the English area just a little bit more
clear than it is right now but in
hindsight there isn't really anything I
can do about that the only thing that
I'll do in the future is and a couple of
smaller trees next to the train track to
make sure that I close it just a tiny
bit more but I also want to keep the
entrance to the English area still open
I know a complete forest forests are
always fun to build and they always look
good but I usually only want to have
them when I don't have so much building
stuff going on
many trees and managed buildings at the
same time is something that I'm not
really a big fan of it's doable and it
won't look bad it's just you're breaking
of both with the buildings that you have
you're breaking the sort of forest idea
that you could otherwise have and with
the trees you are usually obstructing
good facades and things like that of
course like a house in the past if you
have a building that you kind of kind of
on the fence about it doesn't really
look too good place trees in front of it
and you're fine that's kind of how it
works sometimes but in this case I do
want to keep this area a tiny bit more
open which is also one of the reasons
why I wanted to get this foliage in on
the planters in the English area because
as you as you'll notice just by the
planning of the ground where this little
brown sort of like it looks like wood
chips terraforming is where I won't have
future paths and clearly the half of the
entire English area is just paths so I
really wanted to make sure that I get
some good high foliage in on the places
why don't have paths running and when I
still have some grass left that I can't
place foliage on so I do get more of a
green feeling to this to this English
area rather than it being a complete
concrete jungle this is why I by the way
had a bit of a trouble with particles
and handedly and decided to just go with
the Terra painting which to be very
honest I'm still not sure if I'm gonna
go with this there's just a problem that
I was trying to find some good old gray
bricks but couldn't really find anything
that was low enough to fit underneath
the path covers that I had on the side
that was large enough to not cause any
glitches and that just looked good
overall in terms of colour add a couple
big textures that were just really small
and that's a problem that I just run
into sometimes when I'm gonna have some
very wide paths at least this counts for
me if I wanna have some wide paths I
also want to get a slightly larger text
you so you don't get a complete field of
infinite bricks going on and most of
brick sets that I did find and really
small bricks and so you could see easily
see the repetition of the texture
through the path which is something I
don't really like to see
really just destroys any immersion that
you'd have in the game which is because
you know of course you have a seamless
texture on paths and they're all one
tire wide but as soon as you get a
really large area where you fill it in
with just path covers you can clearly
see the repetition and the borders of
the tiles and just not a really big fan
of dots which is why I in the end went
with the terraforming with the Terra
painting effects right now but I'm
actually change that in the future I'm
not too sure about that if I find a good
protection maybe even on Google Images
and make a simple really simple path
text it doesn't even matter too much I
would even like to get that in moreso
than just going for the in-game Terra
painting oh that was a pretty bad boy
scrape by the way I'm sorry about that I
mostly saw this for myself but yeah this
is a bit of supports actually which
still I am really not so used to doing
supports anymore and one thing that I'm
really afraid of when it comes to this
coaster I'm looking in hindsight is the
fact that it is quite under support it
I'm not necessarily the lift hill or the
first section but this last section is
very under supported which I can chalk
up to the picking B mm connectors not
being a finished sets and therefore it
doesn't have pieces for every single
track piece so it's always a bit of a
puzzle trying to get the right track
pieces for the right sort of an tracks
that you have and sometimes you just
gotta get a connector in and you leave a
very large open area that is unsupported
but yeah even though that's the only
thing that I only way that I can really
work around it
I still feel not too happy about those
open places why I don't have enough
supports that's what I feel like now you
could have probably seen the brightness
just suddenly increase and honestly it
looks a bit weird kind of have to get
used to that as well as just because I
went out of its for a while and I
recorded a rollercoaster which means
that I project is on its way you may
have seen it on Jacques Waterloo
creators lounge I am working on
something really stupid in the
background which hopefully is going to
be released soon or might even already
be released while I release this video
that happens just for fun I suppose I'll
say that I'm currently recording this
the 24th of September I'm not sure when
this video will be released so that
might be outdated information at that
point also one thing I just changed the
catwalks and this is the first time that
I've ever used these catwalks and I have
to say they are absolutely amazing they
are only full tile placement it doesn't
have diagnosed it's apparent it's not
really a versatile set it's also in beta
so do have to mention that but it's
Francie's coasters catwalks at and it's
a new set and I like it quite a lot he's
got some really amazing pieces in there
I should probably link it in the
description I actually do remember it
took me quite a while to collect out
those and many people were nagging me
trying to get there trying to get me to
download this app and to be very honest
I need to thank you everyone who
recommended me that sat because it is
really good
it's really got some limitations as well
I don't know if that's because it's a
beta or if that's just gonna stay there
but it does look really good in this
coaster you've got more choice of what
the colors are going to be like then on
the other ones
what is what are they called again it
was like Brandon no it was in Gary Roach
that's it Gary roaches catwalks those
were the most commonly used beam up
catwalks up until this point but
honestly I think these are better since
you can choose more colors on them
they've got a much thicker and sturdier
look to them and now I kind of like just
like them more now with that I see that
I am almost running out of time I think
the only thing that really happened in
this last part was trying to finish the
supports basically I was pretty much it
had a tiny bit of foliage over here
which was really just because I felt
like doing nuts and it wasn't really
sure what else I could really fit in but
with this I think the supports of the
rollercoaster are finished and I should
be able to move on to the facades at
this station in the next episodes so
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you next time
in which I don't know for sure what I'm
going to do but it's gonna be something
else than what you've seen in last
couple of episodes so see that